esta carretera es una de las únicas vías
de entrada y salida de bahamut la zona
ha sido testigo de los combates más
feroces de la guerra hasta ahora las
fuerzas rusas dicen que tienen la ciudad
casi completamente rodeada y es solo
cuestión de tiempo hasta que la tomen el
viernes el jefe de Wagner joylene pidió
al presidente ucraniano bolodimir
selenski que ordenará La retirada de
bajo mud para salvar la vida de sus
soldados pero según dichas tropas no
tienen planes de Rendirse
las fuerzas rusas están intentando rogar
al ejército ucraniano que abandone para
que dejemos de defender la ciudad
esperan hacerse con la ciudad sin
grandes pérdidas pero han perdido a
tanta gente que la catástrofe para el
grupo Wagner y el ejército ruso es
inevitablemente el viernes la agencia de
noticias Estatal rusa riano bosti
publicó estas imágenes muestran un
puente en las afueras de bahamut
reducido a escombros en el vídeo pueden
verse tropas pertenecientes al grupo
Mercenario Wagner afirman que fueron las
fuerzas ucranianas las que destruyeron
el puente intentando detener El Avance
ruso los que conviven en la ciudad y sus
alrededores están sometidos a un
bombardeo casi constante solo quedan
unos 5.000 de los 70.000 que vivían
antes de la guerra y para los que quedan
es una lucha diaria
hay problemas con la comida solo nos dan
alimentos humanitarios una vez al mes no
hay electricidad ni agua ni gas tomar
bahamut sería una victoria altamente
simbólica para Rusia
Moscú considera la ciudad como un
trampolín para tomar ciudades más
grandes como kramators y slowans que más
al oeste